hey it's Justine and welcome to um my
craft room I know I know I just got a
glow Forge Aura and this has pretty much
changed my entire life I have been
having so much fun for the past couple
of days testing this out really learning
how this all works now most people are
familiar with 3D printing well this is a
little bit different this is like 3D
extraction this has a laser that you put
in different materials and you can
actually cut etch you can grave you can
do all sorts of things and what's so
amazing is they have these materials
that are already proof grade they come
from glow Forge and they've got this QR
code so whenever you put this inside of
your glow Forge it'll automatically
detect the QR code and it'll have the
settings precise to the type of material
that you have now there's also a camera
inside of here so right now you can see
on my computer you go to app.
glowforge.com and then you connect it to
the glow Forge you connect it to Wi-Fi
you do the entire setup and then it's
pretty amazing because I have a full
view of what is going on inside of here
as you'll see I have a few things that I
already printed and these are some of
the first things that I've ever printed
on acrylic now originally I did a test
just to see how it would work and I
printed these little name plaques for my
friends were the gaming freaks this is
our clan tag and I made one for everyone
except for myself cuz I ran out of space
on this particular wood board so I need
to make myself one but what's awesome is
when you go into the glow Forge Library
they have all of these projects so you
basically just click one that you like
you can customize it and you click print
and then out you have an an item that
you have just made and it is so much fun
like I'm losing my mind like there's so
many things that I want to make that
being my first test I was like okay
let's step it up a little bit we're
going to move on to acrylic so the first
thing that I did was I tested out these
little skull earrings so you'll see
those right here then I thought okay
these little placards are super cool can
I also make it in acrylic so I made one
of those and I have my sister and I's
podcast name in there called same brain
and there's also a larger version of our
logo now a lot of these images you can
just Import in directly and everything
works perfectly but if you do have a
background in design which I actually do
have a graphic design degree I haven't
really used illustrator or worked much
with Vector so it took me a while to
relearn and figure out how to make this
image work so you can set different
layers and different things on top of
each other and depending upon which you
select if you want it to engrave or to
cut you're then presented with what we
have here and since this is my first
time with the acrylic I'm hoping that it
works so inside of here this is the
camera so that lets us see everything
that's inside of here and you'll also
notice that behind here is an exhaust
hose this connects to a filter that
filters out the air inside of here
because you are burning I mean like
materials that you you should not be
breathing in so if you don't have this
connected to an air filter you can stick
this hose out the window which was
originally my plan but I also got the
air filter which makes it a lot easier
if you are in an apartment building or
somewhere where you can't actually put
the hose out the window I'm I just take
out the crumb
tray oh look at that oh my goodness it
worked okay okay okay progress is being
made that worked out great oh look how
cute these little glasses are this is
incredible look at that it honestly
turned out perfect I can't believe it
now this has a protective coating on it
this protects the surface of your
material so that it doesn't get any
residue or any burning along the edges
so it keeps it nice and clean for you so
they did recommend taking a piece of
tape and that helps you peel up look at
this oh my God it's so cool wow no
freaking way this is so
great so next I have these little skull
earrings which are so
cute look at them so I got a few
different types of earring options
because uh I'm not a crafty girl and I
don't know what I would need so I just
bought all of them and I got the rose
gold ones so look at
[Music]
this these are so
cute and they're super light cuz the
acrylic is a very lightweight material
now it's time to peel back our same
brain logo and see how this one
looks look at him it's our same brain
logo I can't wait to show Jenna speaking
of Jenna I am going to make her a gift
one of the real exciting things about
this for me is I love making custom
t-shirts but it's always really
difficult to make getting the letters
individually at the craft store and
ironing them on well with this I can
basically print make whatever I want on
iron on adhesives and then iron it onto
something so for Jenna I got her this
cute little bag I also got some tote
bags and t-shirts so I think the first
thing that I want to make her is this
cute little tote bag with her name on
it so for the next project I'm going to
walk you through step by step how I'm
going to make this ironon for this
little pouch that I'm going to make my
sister these irons come with a bunch of
different colors so I'm going to use the
silver gold and pink pack and the black
pack and figure out the design that I
want to put on the bag oh those are
pretty and that pink I mean it's like
almost a perfect match for my wall so
for the T-shirt image you are going to
have to mirror it but I'm going to put
this paper in and it'll automatically
detect what color it is have the QR code
up so right now you'll see that on my
computer it says unknown material but as
soon as I close this it will do a quick
scan Eco black ironon we are ready to go
so let's make some text that's nice that
looks like something Jenna would
like let's add a little image shall
[Music]
we I wouldn't say that it's my most
favorite font in the world but we're
going for it so now we're going to hit
Print It prepares the print loads it
into the glow for Jora and there it goes
it's focusing on our
material okay it says this is going to
take 10 minutes and 29 seconds to cut
out the entire project so now all I got
to do is push the button now once I
press this button the exhaust is
automatically going to turn on
everything's all connected and it just
[Music]
works so I actually taped this down
because this was such a light piece of
paper I didn't want it to float away or
move I'm also going to now go in and
recut some of these little designs in a
gold for some pretty little accents and
while I'm doing that I'm going to get
this all prepped and ready to be ironed
[Music]
on I'm not proud to say that I previous
to this have not owned an iron I've only
ironed things in hotel rooms and when
I'm in my own place we just use the
dryer like just put in the dryer or you
just wear it
[Music]
wrinkled and there it
is I hope that Jenna loves it she better
love it because I
worked very hard on this it's so cool I
am so excited I made so many cool things
and this is just the beginning like I'm
just learning how to use this so I can't
wait to explore this more and make some
other awesome things if you guys want to
get more information about the glow
Forge Aura and all things the glow Forge
has to offer I'll put a link in the
description a huge thank you to Glow
Forge for partnering with me on this
video I cannot wait for my new laser
future this is going to be so much fun
if you guys have any suggestions or
anything that you'd like to see me make
feel free to leave them in the comments
below if you guys want to watch more of
my videos there'll be some here right on
the end screen and with that my friends
I'll see you in the next video I got to
go make some more stuff